and welcome tell I don't even know what
to welcome you to welcome to event yeah
first of all I just want to say thank
you brother for you know do you know
what it is in you tell me a freakin
million breaths eight million is just
[ __ ] stupid
I was excited when I got 80 subscribers
or eight for that matter but eight
million I never would have guessed that
in a million years I would have guessed
it it's it's unbelievable that you bros
keep coming and it's it just it makes me
really happy that you posts are still
interested in my videos this from the
bottom of my heart I just wanna say
thank you all for being bros and be
subscribed
I really appreciate every single one of
you that being said this week I was in
Singapore so I'm misty brew a little lot
I was taken there thanks to the star
account Awards we actually won an award
breast I don't know if you knew this but
if we wanted for the best social show
and I say we because I feel like I
wouldn't have accomplished anything it
wasn't for you brother the social star
award goes to cutie pie
so clap it up there good job
Bravo Jenny yeah I have anyone with a
name actually Bravo I don't know Fred I
was going that but yeah it's really cool
to to won an award and I'm really happy
but yeah they asked me to do four clips
to for the other nominees in another
category kind of how do I spell say that
word category they didn't show that well
they had some technical difficulties I
want to show you bras because I put some
effort into them some last-minute effort
but there's a still took me a couple
hours and I want to show them I fold
guys can we just play strip poker
instead okay sure yeah okay thank you
ah I died who your boy has a small
wiener
ha ha how did how does he know that it
was me who killed you oh man I love
playing candy crush
oh man I love crushing candy why don't
you just eat it instead don't you dad
tell me what to do with my candy
I love playing Angry Birds but the game
is so unrealistic
birds are even with harmonic creatures
ever they would never hurt us up that's
what you get [ __ ] dang
that's not Pootie Tang oh yeah pretty
funny food so tonight let me know if you
wanted me to do more sketches I'm
definitely kind to next week there's
gonna be different things don't worry
about it okay
I'm tired they take a lot of time you
know I'm still just one guy making all
these videos pretty much I don't I don't
have any help it's just me and it takes
it takes a lot of time sometimes and
sometimes I'm gonna burn out so I know I
can't complain because I came from like
news illustrating this hotel in
Singapore never mind that
everything is fine I'm just saying
sometimes I agree you bros want so much
from me so many videos and I can't
deliver just as one person like it
literally takes so much time but at the
same time I keep I one YouTube to be
just me I want it to be not this big
thing where I have a production crew and
stuff like that I want you to still be
YouTube for me for as long as I can or
as long as I crack up or something like
that because I feel like people ruin a
little bit the relationship that I have
a new bras so thank you for being rose I
love you stay awesome here's the brophy
yeah